this story is so disturbing using spells
and hexes
how do you prosecute against a hex or
casting a hex on someone the d.a says
larry migliete sent daily messages to
his spellcaster at one point his request
was to harm the man he blamed for their
failed relationship
[Music]
and he resorted to
contacting what are called spell casters
i've never had a case where that was
involved larry went online he hired
people paid them to cast spells on his
wife he was asking for me to
become incapacitated
initially asking for his wife to fall
back in love with him over time when
that did not happen he asked for harm to
be brought to her so she physically
could not leave his side for me to be in
an accident to have broken bones so that
she could stay at home he created altars
where what appeared to be blood
splattered on photos of him and her at
one point he even left a review for one
of these spellcasters calling her kind
and courteous
[Music]
dr catherine luebbe is a practitioner of
filipino indigenous medicine called
hilot which has similar roots to ancient
filipino spell casters or witches spell
casting is
taking the intention
the thoughts
and invoking it into into being there
was surveillance video in the
neighborhood where maya lives showing
her arriving home the night it is
believed she was killed that same video
does not show her
at any point leaving that house
you